in devastating news today Middle Earth
shadow of Mordor executive producer
Michael 4G passed away at 3:15 a.m. on
March 3rd from a rare form of brain
cancer his last few days were peaceful
with his family by his side reads an
update on his YouCaring page where money
was being raised to cover his medical
expenses and support his children's
future Mike was so touched by everyone's
support during his fight his family
wants to thank everyone for their kind
words and support during this difficult
time you caring page was put together in
September at the same time monolith
studios organized an event called for 4G
in order to raise awareness about four
G's position the company encouraged fans
to play in streams shadow of mordor with
the 404 G hashtag according to an update
post in January 4G enjoy a holiday
season with his family and a recent MRI
showed a 15 to 20 percent reduction in
the tumour residing in his brain this
was the last update posted before the
notice of death on March 4th 4G also
worked on the first two years of war
games fable and conquer our thoughts go
out to his friends and family